all right we've got questions and Nate
Segura
he's the Browns senior media broadcaster
he hosts a daily show on ESPN 8:50 it's
Cleveland Browns daily and Nate joins us
now Nate how was that that feeling in
San Francisco last night well it was a
homecoming for me so that part of it was
good then once the game started
unfortunately it was not so good for the
Browns and kind of symbolic of
everything the first carry of the game
for the 49ers Matt breed it goes 83
yards untouched into the end zone and
really unfortunately kind of the rout
was on there it was not a good feeling
and it was very disappointing I think
for this team especially coming off of
what was a good win and a win that you
thought it might be a statement win
against the Baltimore Ravens and
unfortunately they were not able to you
know capitalize on that and stack a win
together and and it just looked like the
49ers had a great game plan and executed
it very well and unfortunately the
Browns couldn't get anything going they
had one opportunity I thought to get
back into that game when they were down
14 to 3 in Antonio Callaway in his first
game back from suspension probably had a
first half he wants to forget and Baker
made a pass to Callaway who was wide
open a little bit behind him but
certainly catchable ends up instead of
being a touchdown deflected into the air
an interception and really that was kind
of it for the Browns all right as they
move forward here you got a got a tough
schedule here in the first half and then
it gets a whole lot easier in the second
half but what what is the remedy that
needs to be taken care of immediately
well I think number one this seam needs
to stop hurting itself I think you look
at the penalties going back to week one
18 penalties against the Tennessee
Titans the turnovers Baker Mayfield now
has eight interceptions on the season he
had three and turnovers last night they
need to stop beating themselves and I
think that's a really a critical thing
year in the NFL especially this season
with all the parody on both sides
I think that's number one and number two
I think it all starts with your
quarterback you were talking about the
quarterbacks from Baker's draft class
before I joined you here and you know
one thing that we thought about Baker
last year that seemed obvious to me was
that he could play the position that was
your question with Josh Hollan could he
play the position
and last year you saw Baker Mayfield
that hung in the pocket that was
decisive in the pocket that was able to
throw the ball on time and accurately
into tight windows his ball placement
was accident excellent his confidence I
thought was excellent and you looked at
everything he said okay well we're just
basically putting Odell Beckham jr. in
for brashaad Pearman and Prasad played
great for the Browns but he was no Odell
Beckham and now you're seeing Baker kind
of not look like himself and I think
it's probably a combination of a lot of
things maybe some with the offensive
line in front of him but I think you
need to get Baker back to where he was
and really he's done that in one game
where he's really looked good and that
was against the Baltimore Ravens and
that was the game where the Browns
offense kind of came unlocked and they
they really put a beating to the Ravens
42:25 in Baltimore so I think it starts
with stop beating yourself the penalties
to turnovers and then Baker just getting
back to being the Baker Mayfield we saw
him be a year ago do we know Freddie
kitchens is a head coach in the NFL I
know he is entitled but it you know some
guys are meant to be coordinators but
you know his temperament you know being
able to handle a big moment there what
do we know about Freddie kitchens so I
think it's very early in the process
with Freddie kitchens but yes I do think
he has had coach material in the
National Football League the guy was the
quarterback at Alabama so when you're
the quarterback at Alabama you do have
some inherent and intrinsic leadership
skills and ability to handle big moments
and pressure and so I think that freddie
is as all of us you know would be
learning kind of on the job given his
rapid ascension here I think that he
absolutely has the year of the locker
room I think he has the respect of the
Browns locker room I think he is a great
leader in a one-on-one setting he's a
good offensive mind and even last night
you saw some of the good innovations
that he was able to put out there even
though overall you would say that was
not a good game I think Freddie kitchens
is the right leader they bounced back
one thing I'll say so far and it's only
week five right now going into week six
the two times that the Browns absolutely
had to answer the call was week two
against the Jets and now the Jets were
not a great opponent but they did and
then really week four against the Ravens
you were facing going one and three on
one in the vision already two games
behind
Ravens and so you had to have that one
and they did it now I think this Sat
this Sunday against the Seahawks who
come in at four and one is going to be a
very very big test but again it's one of
those they've got to answer the call can
they do that and then from there can you
get to the point where you can build and
stack these wins together because that's
all you can do the bright side for the
Browns is and for all the questions that
are about this team right now with all
the hype that came this offseason
you're still one game out of first place
in your division and you beat that team
that's ahead of you already on their
home field so for all things considered
it's not the worst situation to be in
after five weeks even though it feels
very much like a team that has not lived
up to what the expectations were coming
into the season and I'd go back to week
one you beat Tennessee even with this
last year at three and two and I think
everybody feels a lot better about what
you're doing but that was the game as I
said with 18 penalties and they were not
able to get the job done the Browns
should have as much energy as you have
Nate you know I see I see a deem here
you know I've been through a lot with
the Browns in terms of the last seven
years the records the highs the absolute
lows one in 31 and you see a team here
that has a lot of talent I think in some
ways they're still figuring out how to
play together and hopefully that comes
together quickly because you don't have
much time as you pointed out you got
Seattle on Sunday and then you go on the
road to New England and then on the road
to Denver which they had a nice went
over the chargers this week and that's
not just you can't just roll right in
there and beat them at Mile High Stadium
so yes it is it's critical they get
together but there is a lot of town here
there are a lot of good pieces here I
will tell you this to give you one
takeaway from last night I came away
very impressed with the 49ers because
that defense and seeing them in person
they have a bunch of unicorns on that
defensive line five first-round picks
Armstead is huge Bosa is special Buckner
is huge
Solomon Thomas and you go on to a tional
pass rusher that 49er seemed their
ability to get pressure with just four
is very critical you go back to those
giants teams that knocked off the
Patriots how they do it they were able
to get pressure with four and play
seven in coverage and we saw that last
night that made it very difficult for
Baker Mayfield in the Browns you sold on
Jimmy Garoppolo so his ball placement
last night was excellent I liked him a
lot back when the Browns were in there
Neverending quarterback search I thought
that he would be a great guy to come to
the Browns I think the 49ers got a great
great deal getting him for a second
rounder
well I don't think that Belichick wanted
to send him to Cleveland right no I
don't think he did either in fact
somebody once told me that if you were
to come here there would have been a
Cleveland tax that would have made it
prohibitive to do that deal there but I
thought his ball placement was good in
rhythm good is he a guy that if you're
gonna go and get in a shootout with Pat
mahomes is he gonna be able to just
match them throw four throw
shot-for-shot no but in the structure of
Kyle Shanahan's offense and Kyle is just
I think one of the great play callers in
the game today in the structure of that
offense Jimmy Groppo is very effective
and I thought he looked very good is
this you earlier in the season was they
said that sloppy turnover a game against
the Steelers you take that away do you
look very good very efficient to me
Nate good to talk to you get some sleep
that's Nate Segura he's been covering
the Browns for quite some time for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]